[Music]
you'll know the two of us we are the
closest living out here Ellie and me
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true I swear
why you always lying well we've made it
to the end and Joel and Ellie can live
happily ever after wait a minute this
will not end well yes don't fret the
last of us has been renewed for season
two but details are still scarce on
whether it will cover all or part of the
second game however here's what
showrunner Craig Mason told IGN so Neil
and I are just now sort of figuring out
how to because it's more than a season's
worth of Television for sure but I'm
getting ahead of myself and we have a
whole finale to break down I'll be
saving all my part 2 spoilers until the
end of the video but I'll give you a
warning before we get there and hey if
you've been watching my breakdance this
season consider liking and subscribing I
cover lots of cool and interesting shows
plus I have a lot more Last of Us
content coming out in the days ahead we
follow Ellie's Mother Anna as she's
stalked by an infected on the outskirts
of Boston you can see the skyline
matches later we can see all the cuts
and scrapes on her legs from her Escape
now now there's something pretty fun
about the actress who plays Anna being
the same person who portrayed Ellie in
the games the actress who gave birth to
this character is now literally giving
birth to Ellie in the show this is
Ashley Johnson and I for one hope that
if there is a part 3 which is rumored as
being in development hope she comes back
to reprise her role other than her
notably pregnant belly we see she has
these white running shoes which remind
me of the same kind nurses wear in
hospitals we know from the Left Behind
DLC that Anna was a nurse oh and she
said your mom was a nurse which is
probably a good profession to have if
you decide to give birth by yourself in
an abandoned Farm the main events of The
Last of Us take place in 2023 and we
know Ellie is 14 years old so we can
guess that this is roughly the year 2009
or six years after the pandemic notice
the Firefly logo on The Silo indicating
that this is a firefly safe house the
first words Anna says as she enters are
it's me suggesting that she and the
fireflies had plans to meet however no
one's there there after her water breaks
she holds herself up in a child's room
with kid-friendly decorations and drapes
ironically it mimics the location where
Ellie was supposed to die the Pediatric
floor of a hospital filled with quaint
images of elephants and monkeys both of
which can be found in the game the
symbolism of Anna giving birth
underneath the image of a tree isn't
lost on us either as trees literally
flower and produce life just like Anna's
about to do but on the other side of
that door is death an infected who
breaks their way in faster than me at an
all-you-can-eat buffet that man ate all
our shrimp and two plastic lobsters it
is no man it is a remorseless eaten
machine Anna uses her switchblade to
fend off the attack the same switchblade
that will one day come into the
possession of Ellie the American dream
Comics depicts this moment where Marlene
passes on her mother's knife to her
along with a note from Anna herself
there's no note in the show but the note
gives some added context as to why she'd
give her daughter a knife we can make
out the words worth living fight and
make me proud so a switchblade seems an
apt gift in this violent and cruel world
after successfully killing the infected
she looks down to see that she's given
birth note to any pregnant women out
there looking for an effortless birth
just sick and infected on you and voila
unfortunately Anna's been bitten but
this new piece of information could
explain how Ellie got her immunity Ellie
was still connected to the umbilical
cord when Anna was bitten something she
lies to Marlene about this could mean
some sort of resistance carried over but
hey I'm no doctor Anna tells Ellie she's
so tough foreshadowing her daughter's
rough and tough demeanor meanwhile
Marlene and the fireflies are in the
forest with their flashlights making
them look like well fireflies there are
Firefly people with Marlene calling out
for Anna it's clear these two not only
know each other but they were supposed
to meet Marlene will later say they were
delayed getting out of the qz and it's a
good thing they got here when they did
Anna was ready to kill herself her
infection has spread and it's only a
matter of hours before she turns and
kills her newborn if you remember from
the poster from episode 1 a bite to the
leg can have someone change anywhere
from 12 to 24 hours Ellie is hungry but
Anna's been afraid to breastfeed her
fearing it could pass on the infection
Anna's dying wishes for Marlene to take
Ellie to Boston and find someplace safe
to raise her we know that Marlene will
do this but she'll give Ellie over to
ephedra orphanage where she'll later be
shipped at the age of 13 to join the
federal military school in episode 1 we
found out she did this because it was
the safest for her Marlene is the head
of the fireflies and being raised by her
wouldn't be the safest of choices we
also find out that Anna and Marlene have
known each other their whole lives which
makes it extra difficult for Marlene to
do what she and Anna knows has to be
done Anna must be killed one thing this
scene didn't address was Ellie's father
in the game there's not much we know
about him but the show suggests that
he's either dead or not on good terms
with Anna or else Anna would have asked
Marlene to bring Ellie to him Marlene's
life is filled with making difficult but
necessary choices killing Anna here is
but a precursor to the more difficult
Choice you'll have to make later in the
episode whether or not to sacrifice
Ellie in the effort to find a cure now
this is an interesting difference I
found from the game the show calls it a
cure and the game calls it a vaccine
they likely made the switch due to the
political baggage that comes with the
word vaccine nowadays a close-up of baby
Ellie transitions us 14 years later to
present day Ellie wears the same Red Top
from the game and is zoned out and is
barely able to hear Joel you hear me
no did you hear me no this is likely
because she's still traumatized over the
events of last episode where she
brutally killed David the cannibal we
aren't exactly sure how much time has
passed since episode 8. in the game the
David chapter ends in Winter and picks
up sometime in Spring but worry not Joel
has found some delicious Chef Boyardee
the stuff Ellie scarfed down in episode
4. and I know what everyone wants
answered do Joel and Ellie ever get to
Play Boggle really Joel is trying to get
Ellie's mind off things he's never been
the greatest at talking about emotions
but as we'll see throughout the episode
his connection with Ellie leaves him
open to being vulnerable to the point at
the very end in which he openly
discusses his daughter something that
was unimaginable at the beginning of the
season of note is Joel wanting to teach
Ellie the guitar in fact I was thinking
maybe I could teach you yeah once we're
done with this whole thing I'm gonna
teach you how to play guitar remember in
episode 6 he told Ellie he wanted to
become a musician the guitar plays a
larger role in part part two and we
briefly saw a music shop tetan Tunes
while in Jackson so expect this for
season two for most of the season it's
been Ellie wanting to learn things from
Joel and now the shoes on the other foot
with Joel offering Ellie he said he
found a broken guitar in a nearby RV in
the game you can actually Venture into
this RV to make a chilling Discovery a
photo of a family with the backside
reading forgive us the parents shot and
killed their kids then themselves but uh
back to Boggle here we can see the Reno
and Salt Lake City Highway markers just
like in the game and like in episodes 2
and 5 the plan is to find a skyscraper
get a lay of the land and find the
safest route to Saint Mary's Hospital
the supposed location of this secret
Firefly base they were alerted to in
episode 6. in the game this leads the
two through an abandoned bus terminal
while the show changes this location to
a building that was supposed to be
demolished and in both versions Ellie
leaves Joel hanging
oh my god well this leads us to one of
the most memorable scenes in the game
which has been secretly foreshadowed
throughout the entire season and this of
course is the giraffe scene hidden
giraffes can be found all throughout the
show from the streets of Boston Ellie's
room in Jackson her and Riley's room at
the Academy and even on the wall of the
Pediatric unit there are way more
giraffes in the game as well but I may
save that for its own Easter egg video
fun fact the giraffe here is real
production had one brought in front of a
green screen where Pedro and Bella
actually could feed the animal to get
their genuine reactions and take a look
at Joel here experiencing this moment
through Ellie's eyes it's a genuine
father-daughter type moment a few
moments later we'll see Joel walk into
the sunlight it's one of a few times in
the show where we see him bathed in
light and it makes sense considering
this episode is called look for the
light in my other videos I've theorized
the word light is a synonym for Ellie
when we first see Ellie in episode 1
she's bathed in light and episode 2
she's in the fetal position covered in
it so even though the episode is called
look for the light it might as well be
called look for Ellie which is exactly
what Joel does it also ties into the
Firefly motto when you're lost in the
darkness look for the light look for
Ellie a motto that is clearly on display
in front of Joel in episode 1. Joel has
been looking for this light ever since
his daughter died and only now
recognizes that what he's been looking
for is this connection one he's
developed with Ellie in fact he tells
Ellie that when it seems you've come to
an end and there's nothing worth
fighting for you just keep going
you find something new to fight for the
giraffe-filled baseball field is named
after the game's level designer's wife
Bethany Claire field and he had this to
say on his official YouTube channel
always put as many Easter eggs in your
games as you can because they're fun
it's nice to see that this made its way
into the show as well now you might be
asking yourself where did these giraffes
come from well the game offers us a clue
with this advertisement for the Salt
Lake City Zoo now if there are any
zoologists out there let me know if
giraffes could feasibly survive a Utah
winter or infected Mormons there's a fun
CALM Act to episode 2 and the game when
Ellie and Joel remark on The View you
can't deny that view but man you can't
deny that for you you can't deny the
view though now Joel gives Ellie the
chance to turn back here they don't have
to go through with whatever's ahead they
can go and live their lives back with
Tommy in Wyoming but Ellie doesn't want
everything they've gone through to have
been in vain Tess Sam and Henry all died
to get her where she is today only after
they're done can they get that sheep
Ranch Joel wants or or go to the Moon a
call back to Ellie's love for space
along the way they come across a
military medical Camp not to be confused
with fedra these were put up in cities
across the country after the initial
outbreak and Joel opens up about how he
got that scar on his face something that
was referenced in episode three how'd
you get that scar on your head
what is it something lame uh actually it
was a suicide attempt after Sarah's
death Joel tried to kill himself but at
the last minute he flinched and the
bullet grazed his face in the game he
thought about killing himself but
there's never a mention of him actually
attempting it it's great to see Joel
finally open up about his feelings for
most of the show he's been bottling them
up and in one of my favorite lines of
the episode Ellie remarks that time
heals all wounds but Joel retorts it
wasn't time that did it it was her the
show also excludes this moment where
Ellie gives Joel a picture of her and
Sarah this photo was given to her by
Maria back at the hydroelectric Dam I
think this was a pretty good choice as
including it may have come across as
preachy especially considering Joel
blurts out the moral of the story
instead of having the viewer take it in
on their own no matter how hard you try
I guess you can't escape your past that
bastard will Livingston strikes again
with more shitty puns it's an attempt to
lighten the situation and contrast their
sudden capture by the fireflies in the
game this plays out rather differently
on their way to the hospital Joel and
Ellie must Traverse an underground
tunnel filled with bloaters and infected
eventually leading to Joel and Ellie
almost drowning to death before being
captured what makes it even more
terrifying is that Ellie can't swim this
is why Joel has to carry her around
using water pallets in the game her
inability to swim is briefly hinted at
in episode 2. well I I don't know how to
swim
seriously
the game shows us Joel performing CPR on
Ellie before being knocked out by
fireflies the show's version is much
more simplistic with Joel Nelly hit with
some sort of smoke or flash grenade they
could have easily cut to Black here
after Joel is knocked out but instead
they cut to White to keep in line with
the look for the light theme Joel
awakens in the hospital separated from
Ellie and across from him is Marlene the
leader of the fireflies who we haven't
seen since episode 1. fun fun fact the
actress who plays Marlene is the only
one who plays her character in both the
game and show she's lost half her men
just trying to get here and is amazed he
and Ellie made it it was her
she's far like hell to get here I'm sure
she felt like hell to get here Marlene
and the fireflies oh Joel a great debt
and now that he's brought Ellie to them
he can go the last time Marlene saw Joel
he begrudgingly took Ellie but now that
they forged this bond this has
transcended Beyond a simple transaction
I'm pretty sure that Joel who referred
to Ellie as simply Cargo in episode 4
would not consider that today especially
considering what he's about to do
although Joel wants to see Ellie he's
not allowed she's being prepped for
surgery one of the doctors believes
Ellie's immunity has been with her since
birth her body produces a chemical
messenger that makes normal cordyceps
think she is cordyceps hence her
immunity if they can remove this from
Ellie they can reproduce it in a lab and
give it to everyone it's a cure but we
know cordyceps grow in the brain so
removing it would lead to Ellie's death
I'll go more in depth as to who this
doctor is and why he's so important
later on in my spoiler section Joel will
not allow Marlene to go through with
this they have to find someone else but
as Marlene tells him there is no one
else Ellie is their only chance this is
the exact opposite of what Joel tells
Ellie at the end of the episode when he
States they found multiple people with
immunity he even doubles down at the
very end when she asks him to swear that
he's telling the truth this sets the
foundation for part two and raises some
serious questions about choice and
bodily autonomy on the one hand you have
Marlene's point of view she doesn't want
to kill Ellie but believes doing so will
save Humanity it's a necessary sacrifice
for the greater good and on the other
hand you have Joel who wants to save
Ellie even if it means a cure may never
be found no matter which side of the
debate you fall on one thing is for
certain Ellie has no say in the matter
Ellie was never given the choice not by
Marlene or by Joel and by no means is
this an easy decision for Marlene she
has watched Ellie from afar her entire
life promised her mother to keep her
safe and we even catch her shedding a
tear in the game version there is no
mention of Ali his mom this is one
aspect that the show decided to delve
much deeper into Marlene gives Joel
Ellie's knife with plans to escort him
to the edge of town where he'll never
see Ellie again but that's not what
happens as he's escorted by two men it's
only one in the game he takes a brief
moment to examine the hospital directory
trying to locate what level Ellie could
possibly have been taken to in his mind
he's already decided that he's going to
save her and save her he does in what is
arguably one of the most brutal
sequences in the entire show Joel
channels all his anger and shows no
remorse in taking down the fireflies
killing even those that surrender he is
not going to allow the same mistake that
happened to his daughter so you have to
ask yourself is Joel's decision to save
Ellie a selfish one Ellie's the one
that's given him this will to live and
by Saving her it might also Grant Joel
this sense of redemption that's the
beautiful thing about this story that
among the blood and horror are real
human conflicts that raise profound on
questions about what it means to be
human as Joel makes his way closer to
Ellie in the game we get a few tape
recordings that offer more insight into
what the fireflies are doing here one
from the doctor himself who says this
about the surgery with Ellie we're about
to hit a milestone in human history
equal to the discovery of penicillin
more importantly are the recordings from
Marlene which provide greater context
into her decision to kill Ellie and how
she struggled with the decision in a
particularly disturbing recording she
speaks to Ellie's dead mother I
you to know
that I've kept my promise all these
years here's a chance to
all of us is what we were after what you
were after and we also learned that
Marlene was asked to kill Joel but
refused they asked me to Kill The
Smuggler
I'm not about to kill the one man in
this facility that might understand the
weight of this Choice Maybe
and forgive me
I miss you
after Jill destroys nearly every living
soul in the building he makes his way up
to floor six pediatric surgery and
there's just something super creepy
about a man who's just murdered
countless people walking past children's
wallpaper depicting happy animals it's
like when I buy a Happy Meal and find
out I'm still sad one noticeable
difference is the iconic Firefly logo
outside the operating room is not in the
show version Joel makes his way inside
and there on the operating table is
Ellie having just been put under and
this doctor here like in the game won't
give Ellie up and picks up a scalpel
don't come any closer
I mean it
well that went exactly as I thought it
would in the game version Joel runs
carrying Ellie as fireflies descend on
them and there's this cheeky eye chart
that says the word run on it in the
elevator you can just see in Joel's face
the weight of the decision he's just
made but in order for Joel and Ellie to
escape he must get past Marlene she
makes a last-ditch attempt to change his
mind Joel can't be Ellie's protector
forever there will come a day when he's
gone and she'll be torn apart by
infected or killed by Raiders because in
this world the world of Joel's decision
there is no cure Humanity goes on in
this post-apocalyptic mess but let's say
Ellie could save the world it's still
not up for Marlene to decide but what
Joel fails to realize is that it's not
up for him to decide either it's two
people making a decision about what a
woman can do to her body so basically
American politics Marlene puts down her
weapon it's not too late for Joel and
them to find a way to fix this but we
then cut to Joel driving away it's a
brief moment for those who haven't
played the game to wonder if Joel left
Ellie with her but that's far from the
case a groggy Ellie wakes up and has no
clue what happened she wasn't even
informed that they were giving her drugs
to sedate her and here is where Joel
lies like his life depends on it he
fabricates this entire story that the
fireflies perform tests on multiple
immune people and came to the conclusion
that a cure is impossible Raiders that
attack the hospital and Joel grabbed her
and they escaped so not only does he lie
about there being a multiple individuals
who are immune but he omits the part
where he murders dozens of fireflies
including Marlene to save her and that
the fireflies have given up a search for
the Cure when Ellie asks if Marlene is
okay he simply doesn't respond but what
I found really interesting here as Ellie
turns to go back to sleep is Joel
Whispering I'm sorry is he sorry about
what he did that he didn't give her a
choice that he was being selfish that he
lied it could be a mixture of one or all
of these things but I do feel he's
genuinely sorry for deceiving her we get
one final flashback depicting Marlene's
last moments she pleads to Joel to let
her go but he knows that if he lets her
live she'll just come after him in both
versions as Joel and Ellie's car breaks
down Ellie examines her scar it's this
bite that started the whole journey and
now we're coming to its end luckily the
two are a five hour hike to Jackson
enduring their hike Joel mentions how
although they are two different people
Ellie and Sarah would have made great
friends in the game here you can also
collect the last Savage Starlight comic
something we saw Sam Read in episode 5
and Ellie in episode 7. for the most
part these stories from the comics mimic
whatever Joel and Ellie are going
through check out what the final comic
says here The Travelers have been
crippled for now The Travelers represent
the infected daniela's daring plan and
her seemingly miraculous Escape back
home have made her a galvanizing
figurehead to the last watch Daniela is
Ellie and she also escaped back home the
last watch of the fireflies who want
Ellie and finally Captain Ryan's
sacrifice has made him a martyr an
illusion Daniela won't dispel but how
long can she keep what really happened a
secret Captain Ryan is Joel and his
sacrifice is that of humanity he
sacrificed a cure in exchange for
Ellie's life and this comic suggests
deep down Ellie knows this which is why
the final line reads but how long can
she keep what really happened a secret
in the distance we can make out Jackson
and it's here Ellie opens up to Joel
about who she killed in episode 4 she
mentioned there was someone she shot and
now confirms this person was Riley when
she eventually turned infected her name
was Riley
she was the first to die her name was
Riley and she was the first to die
finally Ellie asked Joel to swear that
everything he told her about what
happened with the fireflies was true and
he doubles down and swears it both the
game and show end on Ellie accepting his
answer but there's this seed of doubt
this is not the face of someone who is
completely reassured which leads us to
our spoiler section be warned the next
few minutes will reveal details about
part two Joel's decision here sets the
stage for The Last of Us Part 2 which is
set five years after the events of part
one Ellie develops a distrust of Joel
and the two grow farther apart until
Joel's eventual death Spurs her on a
quest for Revenge this Quest pits her
against Abby Anderson the daughter of
Jerry Anderson the surgeon Joel killed
in Salt Lake City in the show this
doctor is simply credited as surgeon so
there's no telling if he'll be making an
appearance in season 2 as the actual
Jerry Anderson or if the writers intend
on changing things up remember in
episode 6 the the name credited for the
girl who everyone believes to be Dina
was put down simply as staring girl this
allows the showrunners the ability to
recast or shake things up should they
desire now part 2 does begin in the
winter time and with season 2 already
greenlit it would be amazing if they
could start shooting sometime this
upcoming winter but what did you think
of the Last of Us season one I want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
consider liking and subscribing I'm
always coming out with more videos and
have a few Last of Us ones in the
pipeline for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
[Music]
foreign